[Music]
from the director who in a better world
made a malignant sequel
instead comes the final nail in the DC
cinematic coffin and all that's left to
say is rest in this what if I need to
tinkle there's a bucket in the corner
take a bucket piss and call it Granny's
PHT I can't even piss standing up I
could have just peed on it you know the
Romans used to brush their teeth with
their urine superpowers dude I don't
even know how to pee in this thing hey
piss my
C you miss
me is ink piss Aquaman and the lost
kingdom how do you follow up a billion
dooll hit like Aquaman 1 one if you're
Warner Brothers you wait 5 years let
everyone know it won't matter before it
starts throw some Netflix level jokes at
the screen keep your eyes open well
that'll be easy mine don't close and
close out the universe with a man eating
a cockroach trying to smile through the
pain M powerful metaphor for the DCU see
it now before it gets deleted for tax
purposes muscle suit up with Arthur
Curry a man determined not to cut carbs
this time
what's up samworth Che out you got to
work out I
didn't he's embraced fatherhood raising
a child alongside his dad and his wife
don't show her they yell when you show
her single
parents phew he's embraced being a
single dad and rules Atlantis with an
iron fish I'm so bored I don't even know
which end of the Brian King I'm supposed
to be looking at half the time but when
the crack reporters of metropolis
finally discover climate change we've
seen an extraordinary ride and
temperatures reported around the world
Aquaman will take up the fight against a
disaster set in motion long ago that
he's mostly powerless to stop wow
another good DCU metaphor maybe this
movie is smarter than I thought 100
Generations really how many years is
that b geology what is that like a
million years oh never mind black m
returns and he's still very upset about
Aquaman killing his dad but when Yaya an
epic glowing dingle hopper at the bottom
of the ocean he'll be possessed by a
murderous force that haunts him in the
mirror again and become even more upset
about Aquaman killing his dad now to get
his revenge Manta will need a second
bonus meua known as oracal he escaped
with a large stockpile of orac am I
supposed to know what that is a magic
fuel that makes everything light up
green plus it's just a fun word to say
Kane calls it oracal he's using the
storm oracal to heat the planet by
exploiting oracal necris rapidly became
a superpower unlike any other the oracal
furnace is now running at Peak out all
that's stolen oracal it's an oracal
furnace you see how dangerous the oral
could be not the oral try into oracal
challenge difficulty impossible we have
to stop burning the
oracal randomly appearing at odd moments
as if a roller cut way back is Amber
herd's meor who rises from the depths
before getting sidelined by hepatitis C
Patrick Wilson returns as ex king orm
for a little fish out of water comedy
what the hell are you doing I don't know
not used to running and a little bro
Bronte drama with his broiden King of
the brochin do not call me brother do
not call me brother thank
you brother Dr Shin is back who
helpfully keeps an exposition log for
the audience Expedition log it's
incredible that these ancient machines
we found still function after all these
years I don't know how he knows about
this but it all started the day he found
that trident including the only way to
obtain this oracal is to steal it from
highly protected storage vaults also
Nicole Kidman actually returns as Queen
at Lana or at least the 5% necessary to
film her action
scenes so do you think when she said
break feels good in a place like this
she was thinking about the Trident
piercing cord A's chest so Plunge in to
the dceu one final time it's not not
looking too good soak in those precious
final comic book shoutouts my friend
storm tactical operations and pursuit
operative Topo for short synergistic
enter Studio references see going back
to askaban for all I care and and
vulnerable Heroes who are never so hurt
that a good grown can't fix up
but don't worry next year we get to
start all over again with a third
Superman origin story aren't you hyped
please take me with
you starring sunken Idaho orag bird the
poop deck Dark Helmet Shen Aquaman
dolphin the book of Papa wet only merman
in the building gills wide shot and my
claw Green Lantern another heroic whale
finale and another perfect dceu
metaphor Harry water and the Deathly
shallows you know if I had a nickel for
every franchise featuring Jason Mamoa
and worm riding I'd have two nickels
which isn't a lot but it's still kind of
weird that that's happened
twice
attention thank you for your
attention Wayne's World Wayne's World
party time
excellent Intergalactic
Planetary get busy living or get busy
dying oh
biscuits